[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight leaders on both sides of
the island congress in the media in our
intelligence services in virtually every
overfunded think tank in Washington have
suddenly aligned tonight on a single
point of agreement America must go to
war in Syria immediately Bashar al Assad
cannot continue to lead that country he
must be overthrown Assad is an evil man
they tell us his latest crime is a
chlorine gas attack carried out over the
weekend by his forces against a
rebel-held suburb of Damascus Assad's
poison gas suffocated children pictures
of the aftermath of that are all over
the internet and they are horrifying
Assad is a monster that's the official
story almost everyone in power claims to
believe it the push to war in Syria by
the way has United politicians from both
sides Lindsey Graham and Howard Dean
typically agree on very little not much
at all but today they are both calling
for war in Syria Graham is demanding
massive attacks on the Syrian military
Dinah's going even further than that on
Twitter he called the president quote a
wimp for merely sending thousands of
troops and launching tons of bombs at
Syria that's not enough for Howard Dean
who was you may remember once ran for
president as the peace candidate tonight
he wants total war in Syria television
pundits of course strongly agree this
morning the foreign policy team over at
MSNBC explained that it's far more
important for American troops to fight
in Syria than it is to secure our own
border here in America watch there's no
question that now all these years later
is Donald Trump's Donald Trump's
challenge he has to take actions spoken
to McCrone what he ought to do is a
coordinated action there has to be a
comprehensive response as Trump leaves
to fight his imaginary border war he's
leaving the real war where we could make
a difference and said he's turning it
over to Assad and to Iran
and Isis this is something that Barack
Obama wouldn't even do if confronted
with these set of facts Trump has to
take action in Syria everyone nods
sagely that ought to make you nervous
Universal bipartisan agreement on
anything is usually the first sign that
something deeply unwise is about to
happen if only because there is nobody
left to ask sceptical questions and we
should be skeptical of this starting
with the poison gas attack itself all
the geniuses tell us that Assad killed
those children but do they really know
that of course they don't really know
that they're making it up they have no
real idea what happened actually both
sides in the Syrian civil war possess
chemical weapons how would it benefit
Assad using chlorine gas last weekend
well it wouldn't Assad's forces had been
winning the war in Syria the
administration just announced its plans
to pull American troops out of Syria
having vanquished Isis that's good news
for Assad and about the only thing he
could do to reverse it and to hurt
himself
would be to use poison gas against
children well he did it anyway they tell
us he's that evil please keep in mind
this is the same story they told us last
April do you remember that it was almost
exactly a year ago the new
administration announced it was no
longer seeking to depose Assad from
power regime change was no longer our
policy so the usual War course in
Washington started yelping went berserk
and days later Assad supposedly used
sarin gas against civilians in Syria
there was video we bombed a Syrian Air
Base in response to that at the time
this show asked what seemed like the
obvious question are we really sure that
Assad did that
it seems weirdly time to encounter
productive to him shut up they explained
of course were sure what an unpatriotic
question but of course they were lying
two months ago the Secretary of Defense
admitted that actually we still have no
proof that Assad used sarin gas last
year the story it turns out was
propaganda was designed to manipulate
Americans just like so much of what they
say we've seen this movie before and we
know how it ends but just for the sake
of argument let's assume they're not
lying this time let's assume Assad did
just use chlorine gas against kids he's
perfectly capable of that by the way not
defending his moral character let's say
he did do it would that be worth
starting a new war over overthrowing
Assad's regime in Syria would result in
chaos many thousands would die in fact
we might likely see the genocide of one
of the last remaining Christian
communities in the Middle East and we
ought to care about that some of the
dead of course would be American
servicemen a new war would cost us tens
of billions of dollars maybe hundreds of
billions
would it make America safer would it
make the region more stable let's see
how exactly did regime change work in
Iraq and Libya doesn't matter say our
moral leaders on CNN and everywhere else
atrocities like this cannot be tolerated
okay but let's be real we do tolerate
atrocities like this all the time for
example there's a devastating famine
killing children in Yemen right now the
Saudis are causing that famine should we
drop tomahawks on Riyadh and response
not until it's on YouTube apparently
when you conduct foreign policy by viral
video pictures are essential but in real
life Syria is a highly complicated place
with Assad gone who would run it exactly
do we have another strongman in place to
install or is it our hope that a stable
democracy will magically appear in the
wake of this protracted Civil War and
who exactly are these moderate rebels
you're always hearing about the ones
that we're supporting with your tax
dollars well a lot of them turn out to
be Islamist crazies for example the city
where the chemical attack just occurred
is mostly controlled by the army of
Islam it's a radical group that is
called for establishing an Islamic state
under Sharia law in Syria that group's
founder called for exterminating all
Shia Muslims and Al whites from the
country but we're supposed to wage a new
war on this groups behalf why is that
exactly back in 2013 when the Syrian
civil war was still in its early days
one onlooker weighed in on Twitter
here's part of what he wrote quote we
should stay the hell out of Syria the
rebels are just as bad as the current
regime what will we get for our lives
and billions of dollars
zero in another tweet he said this quote
let the Arab League take care of Syria
why are these rich Arab countries not
paying us for the tremendous cost of
such an attack
and yet another tweet he said this what
will we get for bombing Syria besides
more debt and a possible long-term
conflict of course you know who wrote
that was Donald Trump and he was right
and that's one of the reasons he got
elected president and now the same
people who brought you a dying American
middle class undefended American borders
and endless pointless wars in countries
you could not find out a map are telling
the president he's got to depose Assad
for reasons that are both unclear and
demonstrably dishonest and by the way it
may happen but before it does Congress
ought to consider a brand-new
constitutional amendment let's call it
the Lindsey Graham amendment and here's
what it would say Congress shall topple
no government until it finishes
rebuilding the last government it
toppled and furthermore talkshow
generals shall be required to personally
visit the battlefield of every war they
advocate for end of amendment that would
have an immediate and positive effect
let's hope it passes